PLACES LIKE WHERE BILL WAS.
MORE ON THIS NOW.
LET'S JOIN WITH TEXAS DPS
LIEUTENANT CHRIS OLIVARES.
I WAS WITH YOU THE PAST 10-PLUS
DAY.
YOUR REACTION TO THE NEWS THAT
MEXICO HAS EFFECTIVELY GIVEN
THESE ALMOST 15,000 STRONG
CARAVAN A PASS TO HEAD STRAIGHT
TO THE BORDER ACROSS FROM YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, GRIFF.
THAT GOES TO SHOW YOU RIGHT
THERE, THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY OR NOT
FULFILLING THEIR AGREEMENT TO
STOP THESE CARAVANS FROM MAKING
IT TO THE U.S. BORDER.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT, GRIFF.
WE SEE THEM WE KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BRANCH OFF INTO
SMALLER GROUPS AND WHEN THE
SMUGGLING ORGANIZATIONS TAKE
OVER AND FOR THE MOST PART
WE'LL PROBABLY SEE THE PEOPLE
MAKE IT TO THE PATH OF LEAST
RESISTANCE, EAGLE PASS AND DEL
RIO AND TRYING TO MAKE THEIR
WAY ACROSS INTO THE SECTOR.
AGAIN, WE'RE OUT HERE THIS
MORNING, AND AGAIN, IT'S BEEN
NONSTOP AND YOU WERE HERE THIS
PAST WEEK AND SAW ALL THE
ACTIVITY IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY.
AND THE RUNNERS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT, OVERWHELMING FOR
BORDER PATROL AND ESSENTIAL TO
HAVE DPS AND NATIONAL GUARD
WITH THEM TO PROVIDE AT THAT
SUPPORT.
GRIFF: I WAS THERE THROUGH
THURSDAY.
ON THAT MORNING, THERE AT THE
PORT OF ENTRY, 22 POUNDS OF
FENTANYL APPREHENDED.
THAT'S ENOUGH TO KILL FIVE
MILLION AMERICANS ACCORDING TO
DEA.
LET ME SHOW OUR VIEWERS,
LIEUTENANT, IF I CAN, WHAT THE
BORDER PATROL CHIEF ORTIZ PUT
OUT THIS WEEK ALONE.
THE ENTIRE U.S. BORDER, 800
PLUS POUNDS OF COCAINE, ALMOST
500 POUNDS OF METH.
ALMOST 200 POUNDS OF MARIJUANA.
SEX OFFENDERS, GANG MEMBERS,
FELONS, TWO MURDERERS.
DO AMERICANS FULLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER?
>> AT SOME POINT IN SOME
PERSPECTIVE, I BELIEVE THEY
DON'T.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE'S
COVERAGE SHOWING WHAT'S TAKING
PLACE AND A GOOD EXAMPLE WHEN
YOU'RE HERE WITH US AND
ACTUALLY BEING OUT THERE, ON
THE GROUND AND SHOWING WHAT'S
TAKING PLACE AND BILL MELUGIN
HAS BEEN DOING IT SINCE LAST
YEAR AND TAKING PLACE AND
ACTUALLY SHOWING THE HARD WORK,
FROM BORDER PATROL, DPS
TROOPERS AND NATIONAL GUARD AND
CHASING DOWN THE SINGLE ADULTS
AND LARGE GROUPS COMING ACROSS
AND THE DRUGS AND CRIMINALS
COMING ACROSS.
IT'S A COMPOUNDING EFFECT WHEN
YOU SEE MASS MIGRATION,
BECAUSE, WHAT COMES WITH THAT
IS AGAIN, AS I MENTIONEDS THE
SINGLE ADULTS, THE RUNNERS,
CRIMINALS AND COMING THROUGH
THE PORTS OF ENTRY AND HOW IT
AFFECTS NOT ONLY THE STATE OF
TEXAS, BUT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
AGAIN, IT'S JUST GOING BACK TO
SHOW HOW ESSENTIAL IT IS IN
PROVIDING PERSPECTIVE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHAT'S REALLY
TAKING PLACE ALONG THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
>> LIEUTENANT, THIS PAST WEEK,
WE SAW VICE-PRESIDENT HARRIS
TRAVEL OUT TO THE LEAGUE OF
NATIONS, OUT TO CALIFORNIA AND
PLEDGE NEARLY $2 BILLION FOR
THE ROOT CAUSES IN THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE, CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES 6 HONDURAS, HE
GUATEMALA, EL SALVADOR.
IS IT YOUR VIEW THEY NEED TO BE
MORE WHERE YOU ARE, AT THE WORE
DER TO ADDRESS THE
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS.
>> ALLOCATING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES WHERE 90% OF
THE IMMIGRANTS COMING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER, INCLUDING MEXICO.
THAT HAS NOT DONE ANYTHING TO
SLOW DOWN THE MASS MIGRATION
AND SINGLE ADULTS AND CRIMINALS
COMING ACROSS.
THEY SHOULD DIVERT THE
RESOURCES TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST MONEY AND
FUNDING, THEY NEED TO ENACT THE
POLICIES THAT WERE EFFECTIVE
PRIOR TO 2021, THAT WAS
WORKING.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
NOW IS FOCUS ON THE POLICIES AS
FAR AS ENACTING THOSE POLICIES
WHAT'S 0 WORKING AND PROVIDE
THE SUPPORT TO BORDER PATROL
BECAUSE THEY NEED IT RIGHT NOW.
GRIFF: LIEUTENANT CHRIS
OLIVAREZ, I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
AFTER THE NEARLY TWO WEEKS, I
SPENT WITH YOU AND LIEUTENANT
LUPE AND EVERYBODY DOWN THERE,
DESPITE THE SURGING NUMBERS,
I'VE GONE OUT EVERY SINGLE DAY
AFTER THE SUN COMES AND AND
GONE AFTER THEM AND I KNOW THE
MORALE I